je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on se moque
ou peut-être en huit comme ça maintenant
nos petites tagliatelles pas question
d'improviser pour livrer mazza 10 à
pizza de concours sera une oeuvre d'art
des tagliatelles de légumes une sauce
hollandaise il du homard comme produit
phare c'est un produit noble qui qui je
pense peut peut amener quelque chose sur
la pizza même si d'autres
je pense que rang auront cette idée là
je pense que ça peut être très
sympathique à travailler de part ses
couleurs de part son vous à quatre mois
de la finale des championnats de france
la recette est bien avancé mais pas
encore finalisé aidé par un ami
cuisinier coach pour l'occasion le
pizzaïolo doit encore peaufiner sa patte
et travailler sa base mais ça peut être
sympa avec les légumes
reste ensuite à bien maîtriser la
cuisson des différents ingrédients on a
quand même le croustillant le la
difficulté les lacets que sur une pizza
c'est pas comme sur une assiette et ça
repasse au four ça réchauffe ou voir sa
recrue dans un four à 300° plus donc
c'est là où c'est la difficulté du trou
tu vois là mais au niveau de l'harmonie
on est pas mal le jour du concours
olivier matadi aura quinze minutes pour
composer sa pizza et quelques une de
plus pour la cuire face à lui un jury de
quatre experts qui évaluera d'abord la
qualité de la pâte puis l'aspect et les
saveurs du produit fini les critères
auxquels le pizzaïolo berruyer reste
attentif à chaque séance de préparation
pour les championnats de france je pense
qu'il manque un peu de deux couleurs
bon bah on va remédier à ça olivier la
pâte m'a l'air d'être sympathique la
cuisson également donc apprendre à
goûter le lot marquant même pas voir si
au niveau de la cuisson mais je dirais
dans le dans la conception où il a peu
près c'est à peu près ça je pense qu'on
est on en est pas loin
pour sa première participation olivier
maladie espère atteindre le top 20 des
meilleurs pizzaïolos un défi relevé car
le 19 mars prochain ils seront 150
professionnels de la pizza à concourir